and the starter tonight for the texas
rangers will indeed be spencer howard 16
games 12 of those starts so far this
year is yet to record a win and overall
7.38 era does have 43 strikeouts in his
39 innings
luis roberts sends this ball into center
field so he will take first base on a
hit
[Applause]
second base solac
turn from kiner falefa is wide again and
this one climbs the netting and ends up
out of play abreu's going to second base
three and two
that's ball four
one two pitch
a swing and a miss jimenez strikes out
and lance lynn who's on the mount for
his 26th start of the year looking for
his 11th win as era at two and a half
and it'll strike you out high fastball
first strikeout of what we expect to be
more than one tonight for lancelin
as this pitch
misses low ball four and garcia draws
the two out one
he has ten steals this year
lance's pitch is
sliced out into left field ximena's on
the move and he starts to go down to a
knee and the ball falls in front of him
to second
romy
pour out number three
2-2
and then strike three called so
back-to-back strikeouts for spencer
howard
as he heads down to first with a one-out
walk
on the ground to furs low on the charge
spun it to second and another ridiculous
throw
that nearly took out another bad boy
hits his ball up the middle that's a
single
calhoun with a rangers second hit of the
ball game
this should end the inning
deloitte left makes the catch
[Applause]
strikes out here third strikeout of the
night for howard
and there is ball four moncada takes a
one-out walk
one-two
and this one up the middle lined right
into the glove of connor philippa in the
inning
he's not gonna get on strike three on a
fastball to the corner from lancelin
[Applause]
connor for left foot or right oh goodwin
keeps it snow coned and i believe he did
catch it drew anderson comes in the ball
game on for the sixth time it's the area
of four and a half
well it was a miss with a change up and
it's ball four
three balls two strikes there goes gavin
garcia hits it off the mound and the tag
there is late over at second by connor
falefa and the sox will have two on
with one out three two
swing a bouncing ball to first could be
two low to second for one kinder
philippa back to first in time double
play with anderson covering
low spikes out swinging
hits his ball hard up the middle and
that one gets through for base hit
and so ibanez is on with one out of the
fourth inning there we go
[Applause]
three two there is a ground ball third
base montana goes to second but it's bob
old and everybody's safe
full count pitch and that's outside ball
four bases are loaded
and they're looking for jonah heim to do
some damage here banya is at third solac
at second calhoun at first
and he
bounces one up the middle little bobble
to step on the back for one to throw to
first in time oh no a double play
would in the inning jonah heim arguing
that they didn't get him well there it
is
so the first run of the game scores on
the fielder's choice for jonah high
three balls two strikes
and there is ball four monkatto will
give jose a shot on the fifth walk
tonight for sox hitters and usually that
means good things later on
in the ball game oh two pitch
the swing of the miss strikeout
oh two
struck him out lance been working on
that change-up and he threw two of them
to get strike three
little weak bouncer third base bare hand
by moncada the throw to first not in
time
kennefalefa is in
that's pretty good here he goes to
gonzalez that connection successful
there's a double play
now yasmani
and he takes a pass at this ball in the
center field this ball game tied
just hammered by 24.
well as hard as the sox have hit the
ball
in this series
that could very well be as hard as any
ball hit because it's just to the left
of center it went out of the ballpark
probably hit 425 feet
2-2 pitch
bouncer that one's through base it for
nathaniel his second hit of the night
[Applause]
less than two and a half runs per game
now there's a base hit by banya second
hit of the inning
and it is the first inning of the night
where the rangers have had multiple hits
[Applause]
in the pine third base side
has nowhere to throw it to in second
soda first just in time it's about time
and garrett crochet comes on and he's in
a jam he's got runners in second and
third only one out on for the 48th time
big spot right here low at third
ibanya's at second base and so here's
peters
that's a base hit up the middle
peters brings home one
here comes the third of the play
and they got a bagnes that's a really
good effort good call by chris guccione
a great throw by luis and the artificial
surface makes it a true hop
little tapper from romee to third base
and that is an infield single for romy
gonzalez
so here's moncada he's walked twice and
reached on a fielder's choice the 2-1
delivery that's swung on engulfed in the
ear to right center garcia back track at
the wall leaps up and he's got it
what a catch by adolesce garcia
taking away extra bases and possibly
more from johann moncada
and sending us to the stretch in style
just hasn't been a lot of offense in the
game
all around this little flare will drop
in base hit into right field and it's
another multi-hit game for keiner falafa
that's a 40th multi-hit game for kenner
falefa this year and there's a line
drive out into right field that's a base
hit
philippa the third
on the garcia single and the rangers
have them cornered
second and third two strikes two outs
and there is strike three at a hundred
michael kopeck the texan walks off the
mound in arlington
something
he didn't it's ball four grandahl is on
with one down in the eighth
that's ball four so the sox
have waited out santana to the tune of
two walks to this point
this one line to second and right there
the inning
is over boy that's a huge out
on three and two he struck him out how
about that some confidence there in the
breaking stuff from kimbrell it's 3-2 to
peters and that's off the play ball four
pitches up high throw down to second
peter's got a good jump and he steals
that one cleanly
3-2
cold strike three
joe barlow is on here in the night it's
been a great year for joe barlow this
will be the 26th game of the season for
him
so comfortably as he gets a swing and a
miss
by goodwin
swinging a high fly ball center field
not going to carry
for
gonzalez two out
two two
and a swing and a miss strike three
barlow
finishes it with a punch out in the
rangers
take this one from chicago two to one